Stephen Amell who plays green arrow and this is a show this is a show i watch with this is a show i watch with my children and so I know this show well he has said that he would like to do a crossover on to your show is that something that something it is that something you would want I'm not sure I have a show I don't want just random people crossing over into my show I have standards I want a group it's like a private club I want to lift a rope let's sum in and then like I'm not sure you know let the green arrow in flash I'm not sure you know how is it with you guys be odd tonight on Law & Order arrow there have been a lot of Stephens a big guy you're a large man you so that's very large very large powerful man where he'd want some Apple boxes and stuff to stand on so I you know he he was not here last year was he really yeah he's very bitter that you said that you